thank you jc all right let's look here
because our prompter is not up there
southwest medical associates the sponsor
of this next segment are helping us
celebrate some of our local volunteers
it's time to introduce you to this
month's hospice hero
what drew me to becoming a hospice
volunteer was recent training i spent
two years at the aquinas institute of
theology
and earned a certificate in healthcare
mission leadership and i also
finished a year certificate in positive
psychology and i think just a normal
need to want to help people in any way
that i can what i try to do is first
establish a form of of a compassionate
trust
and i think that's very important i use
a little pecking chicken
which is obviously funny
but as it pecks around it does bring a
smile to the family
and lpc to me is not little picking
chicken but it is love patience and
compassion
and it begins my process
of discussion no one knows exactly
how the volunteer is going to be
received but if a trust can be built
and if a discussion can begin then i
think
there are good possibilities it will be
the outcome
i
like music i bring my ukulele and i play
a little bit
[Music]
so it helps with mood it helps to relax
all involved in starting with myself
and music i think is an amazing
healing
possibility sometimes the patients may
be a bit weak
they have a voice that can't quite be
heard but they will be singing and you
can feel it from the heart
sometimes there's a lack of conversation
so if you have an awesome book of
useless facts oh my goodness
how many times per minute does a
butterfly uh flap its wings nobody knows
nobody really cares but it again
provides a bit of relief from anxiety
and helps
the conversation ensue
and from there i try to to understand
the patient and
appreciate their life story after all
i'm there to learn more about them one
very special memory for me
recent patient and the fellow had a very
weak voice and
we started to
to sing a little bit and he said i don't
know if you'll be able to hear me sing
but as his voice began to get stronger a
grandson said mom
granddad is singing
and to me it was a moment of joy for the
family
and just for the process of of the
volunteering that i'm trying to do
through optum and
southwest medical but i think if someone
has the ability to connect to people
and has a feeling about helping them and
wherever they may be in their journey
then yes i would absolutely recommend
optum and southwest medical people are
wonderful they're caring
they're organized and by all means
they're dedicated to their craft
thank you southwest medical associates
for sponsoring this segment
if you're interested in becoming a
volunteer just call
702-671-1111.com we'll be right back
right here